but Germany has announced it will
increase controls on its border with
Poland and the Czech Republic in an
effort to prevent more migrants entering
the country the new measures would begin
immediately said interior Minister Nancy
faza the announcement came a day after
police raids in Germany found more than
100 Syrian citizens inside Apartments
searched in connection with a smuggling
ring
well for more details we're joined by
Dominic Kane on the German Polish border
Dominic what exact measures have they
introduced here
what's being introduced what Nancy feasa
announced a few hours ago is what she
calls flexible Mobile Spot checks of
people crossing the border with the aim
of cracking down on people smuggling
because the number of people who who the
police in Germany are aware of having
illegally as it were being smuggled into
this country in the course of August was
67 percent higher than in the previous
August why am I where I am right now
well this is a busy border crossing
point this is Frankfurt under order on
the German side and still bits of the
town of stubitza on the other side you
see the people walking along the bridge
basically walking across the border from
Germany into Poland and vice versa well
the German government has absolutely no
idea who they are who the people driving
the cars are that are coming across into
their territory or leaving Germany into
Poland and it wants to know specifically
what people are coming across so it's
border controls perhaps not here in a
regular way but they intend to introduce
the Border controls at lots of different
parts of the frontier the problem well
the Border area from Germany to Poland
Germany to the Czech Republic is more
than 1 600 kilometers long and there is
no way that they are going to be able to
patrol as it were all of those border
points the police have said they can't
do it they don't have the resources
which is why antifiza says bring it in
now in a mobile flexible way to Target
people's modeling why do they feel
they've got to introduce these measures
now why now
there's been a lot of pressure on the
German government both within Germany
and without as it were beyond the German
borders specifically for the German
government to to give some as it was
steer in terms of migration politics is
concerned we know there's a meeting in
Brussels taking place tomorrow at which
the idea of Reform to the migration pact
that binds together EU policy is going
to take place there has been a lot of
pressure on the Germans who said well
they are they had issues with the idea
of controlling the number of migrants
coming number of refugees coming and set
and had said that they weren't prepared
to play ball as it were well now Mr
shots the chancellor says well we don't
want to stand in the way of some form of
progress but the key issue here is right
up and down the Border areas in Germany
the big States Bavaria Brandenburg
estate I'm in now Saxony Saxony anhad
you have elected officials saying they
believe that where they are logistically
right now the refugee crisis of 2015
when the number of people coming to
their country and asking for Asylum well
they think they are approaching that
sort of tempo now that's why you see the
minister making the decisions that she
has made and yet there was so much
pressure on her she had seemed to
indicate one policy then another now she
says she's sticking with this what the
police have asked for mobile flexible
spot checks but let's be clear people
crossing me Crossing going past me now
Crossing into these borders the
government's opponent in Germany have no
idea who's coming and going that's what
they're trying to control okay thank you
so much for that that is Dominic came
for us on the German Polish border